dear mom these are the flowers I would
have bought you and this is the card I
would have written you I've spent most
of my life trying to fill in the blanks
asking everyone around me about you the
memories of you tucked away in a box in
the Attic I don't remember what your
perfume smelled like or what made you
laugh but I'll never forget lying in
your hospital bed drawing pictures with
you
you're a rebellious little six-year-old
I'm writing this because I want to tell
you that you were so strong that I wish
you didn't have to look your daughter
knowing that you'd never see her get
taller get heartbroken get married I'm
sorry that I always made you picked me
up when you were so weak that I tripped
over your IV pull the Christmas I
complained that I didn't get what I
wanted being afraid of your wig I'm
sorry for the fits I threw that I love
you moms they never got to say and I'm
sorry that it's taken me 21 years to
write this card and it's still not
perfect I'm writing this because I'd
give anything just to be able to fight
with you
I never got to ignore your phone calls
because you're too overbearing I never
got to introduce you to girlfriends or
boyfriend's that you say are bad for me
and I tell you that you don't understand
but months later I realize you were
right
I'm writing this because I'm angry that
I have to live life only part way all
the yearbook pictures I took without you
to do my hair the lunches I made myself
I feel like I'm missing out on a huge
part of being a woman because you're not
here like a part of me is in that coffin
with you holding onto your leg while I
scoot across the floor begging you not
to go
you are so beautiful it's insane to
believe that anyone was beautiful to see
you ever existed on this earth I'm
writing this because I wish you were
here I wish you could see the woman that
I've grown into I wish I knew which
flowers you liked and that I could put
them in your hands rather than on a plot
of grass with your name on it I'm
writing this because I want to say thank
you
no matter how sick you are all you
wanted to do is make sure I felt loved
thank you for taking me to Disney World
while you're in a wheelchair letting me
draw those pictures in your hospital bed
writing me letters like you knew I grew
up to be Who I am making me feel like I
was so special and so smart I feel like
I'll always be that six-year-old with a
mind of her own that didn't take orders
and doesn't wear dresses that's still
waiting for her mom to wake up and tell
her that everything's okay again I'm
writing this because I'll never love
anyone as much as I miss you happy
Mother's Day